>>Announcer on video: In order to identify
and empower such individuals, I
am proud to announce that my Aunt Doris Buffett
is
committing $10 million to endow Learning by
Giving, a
foundation that will be central to the development
of
the social value investment model by fueling
a pipeline
of young leaders who will identify and fund
the most
impactful projects across America. The premise
is
simple: The foundation partners with universities
to
create courses in philanthropy and nonprofit
studies.
Each class at each school is then given a
$10,000 grant
and students collaborate to identify the best
allocation
for those funds in their local communities.
The
students prepare reports on what they've done
and share
them on LearningByGivingFoundation.org, an
online
resource where coursework is made available
to everyone on
the planet. The web site was built using Google
tools
and resources, and with the generous support
of Google's director
of university relations and many of their
employees.
LivingByGivingFoundation.org is going live
today, and I
encourage every one of you to use it and to
share it. [voice fades]
>>JENNIFER: And we welcome >>DORIS Buffett
with us today.
>>DORIS: Thank you.
[Clapping]
>>DORIS: I'm very happy to be here. This is
been quite an experience you know.
>>JENNIFER: Well, we hope you've enjoyed it.
For those of you that don't know me, I'm Jennifer
Barth,
and I work here, recently in the engineering
office and
now in the office of the executive chairman.
So that
keeps me little busy on the side.
>>DORIS: It would.
>>JENNIFER: But this is way more fun today,
I
want you to know. [giggles]
>>DORIS: Good.
>>JENNIFER: So I have to say, in looking at
all
of my research, you've led a pretty interesting
life.
>>DORIS: Yes. I think so. It's had its ups
and downs and I'm a late bloomer, but I'm
having a lot of fun
now.
>>JENNIFER: Hey, that's right. That's right.
I mean, your father was a Congressman?
>>DORIS: Yes.
>>JENNIFER: Your brother's a little famous.
>>JENNIFER: Just a little. You've obviously
had some relationship -- tumultuous relationship
history
with your mother that you talk about a lot
in your book.
>>DORIS: Oh, yes. That's true.
>>JENNIFER: Millionairess.
>>DORIS: Yes.
>>JENNIFER: Not once, but twice.
>>DORIS: Right.
>>JENNIFER: So --
>>DORIS: Lost it all the first time.
>>JENNIFER: Yes. And to bad luck; not to
anything that you cover done differently?
>>DORIS: No. Considering all the circumstances
it probably was inevitable.
>>JENNIFER: So I think it's interesting you
didn't necessarily want to tell the whole
story in your
book, Giving It All Away. Not initially.
>>DORIS: Well, no. It's painful, but in order
to get the whole picture, you have to know
the whole
story. So we went ahead and did it, and as
my brother
said, it's a very honest book.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: So if nothing else, it's an honest
book.
>>JENNIFER: So what changed your mind?
>>DORIS: Well, my brother did. We were on
a
plane and she said, "Doris, you've got a write
a book
about what you're doing." I said, "Oh, for
heaven's
sakes. I don't know anything about that."
He said,
"Well, you've really got to." I said, "Well,
it's
all -- it's all anecdotal." He said, "That's
what
people love." I said, "Well, I don't know
how to
write." He said, "I'll get you a ghost writer."
So
he's rather persuasive and I actually went
back to my
seat and I thought, well, I've got the title,
and that
would be Here's the Deal because everything
we do is
'here's the deal'. It involves collaboration.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: So they voted that out so that was
too
bad.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: And then Bono actually advised me
to
do it. How about that.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So that was very persuasive.
>>JENNIFER: I bet so.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So that's how it came to be, and
I
knew a fellow in Fredericksburg, who was a
wonderful
writer and worked for the Freelance Star,
and he was
eager to do it. So we just got together and
I just went
on, and on, and on, and he was game to take
it it all
down and I was very happy with the result.
>>JENNIFER: It's fascinating. I am curious
because you've come from so many different
highs and
lows. How did you know you could do this?
I mean,
you've been -- I'm the mom of a four-year-old,
full-time
career at times, you know, you struggle. I
was an actor
at one time so I know some way of feast or
famine.
>>DORIS: Yeah.
>>JENNIFER: How'd you know you could do this?
I mean, you've got philanthropy and organizations
touching lives on a one-to-one basis.
>>DORIS: Well, that's what we try to do. First
of
all, that was my aim. I wasn't going to go
into more
esoteric things. I wanted -- I had the money
and I was
very lucky to have that, and it fit into who
I am. I'm
not a saint, I'm not saying that, but I have
always
been aware of other people's needs and wished
to help
them, and now I can just go full gun. I was
-- it was
wonderful. I was all ready to go. I already
had a
501(3) when my mother died, so I was out of
the starting
gate.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: I made a few mistakes in the beginning,
but
not many, because I had a wonderful group
of people were
working with me who were very bright, and
that was our
aim and has remained our aim, and we just
keep on doing
it as long as the money holds out.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: Eventually the last check will bounce
and then I'm out of business.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: Let's hope not. I'm curious. Can
you recall that first instance where you wrote
that
first really large check or you got that first
letter
back from someone that you made a difference
in their
lives? Can you recount something like that?
>>DORIS: Well, I know that -- I know the very
first thing we did was to offer scholarships
for
women -- and that's after everybody else had
turned them
down -- so we took the losers -- and all of
them
graduated, just one didn't. So that was very
successful
because I had a marvelous young woman who
said she never
wanted any children and now she had 135.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: And she rose to the occasion, and
she's a mother hen so that worked really well.
And then
the next thing was to educate battered women
-- formerly
battered women. So that's worked out fairly
-- when you
change a life like that, it's really dramatic.
>>JENNIFER: Sure.
>>DORIS: So then I thought up this, the
Learning by Giving --
>>JENNIFER: That's right.
>>DORIS: -- and thought why am I doing this
all
by myself? [chuckles] So here we have a whole
generation of
extremely bright and energetic people and
they're
idealistic, and they're hard working, so why
not get
them in on the game. So that's how we first
started with
this, which has become a really big deal across
the
country. I'm so old that I remember when Communists
were a big threat, and I remember that they
used to go
to universities and colleges and pick off
the 5 percent
that were the most compassionate and the brightest
and
recruit them. So I thought, well, it worked
for them,
you know, so I think I'll try that, too. So
that's what
we try to do.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: And it has worked. It is working
as
we speak.
>>JENNIFER: Right. So it appears that your
brother and Bono were right.
>>DORIS: Well, I'd like to think so.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: I want to know, you mentioned
one
time about growing up in the childhood you
had, and the
education you learned through life experience
about a
fairy god mother. What's your idea of a fairy
god
mother?
>>DORIS: Me [chuckles] now.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: No. I always wished -- I was in a
very difficult situation and I always wished
there was a
fairy god mother would come along and just
kidnap me, or
take me away, or straighten it out or show
me some
sympathy, whatever it was, but that never
happened so
then I'm now becoming my own. And I'm making
myself
happy doing this, and then thousands of people.
Literally thousands of people and I don't
want to sound
braggadocio, but it has changed their lives.
Their
letters are magnificent. I have a whole stack,
and that
represents 1/100ths, probably. But these are
the most
touched by it and their lives are really changed
and
they're so grateful, and their children are
doing well
by it. Everybody's doing well by it.
>>JENNIFER: Do you think if you hadn't had
your
own misfortune that you would feel to this
extent to do
what you do?
>>DORIS: I think I'm a little weird. I don't
think probably -- you know, what I look at
my
generation, I don't think so. I mean, I do
know --
well, I shouldn't be so hard on myself. I
always find
people who I felt needed some help and tried
to do, you
know, in my own little teenybopper way, something
to
help out. But what can you do? I mean, I was
bound by
the family rules. To begin with, I was living
under
their roof, and "When you're living under
this roof you
will obey the rules," that kind of thing.
And so I
didn't have a lot, and I didn't have any money
except
what I made babysitting.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: You --
>>JENNIFER: You've come a long way.
>>DORIS: What's so funny about that?
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So yeah. But I was always aware.
I
always was aware. When I was in high school
I did have
one of those 'Save the Children' kids from
World War II,
and I don't know of anybody else that did
that. So
yeah. It was there. It was in place and all
it needed
was some money.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: And maybe some wisdom. Yeah.
>>JENNIFER: Well, you had the Sunshine Lady
Foundation, which has helped countless women,
as you've
said; and then also you've helped those in
prison to get
educated and turn themselves around.
>>DORIS: Mm hmm
>>JENNIFER: Tell me about the transition from
the Sunshine Lady Foundation to the Learning
by Giving
foundation.
>>DORIS: Well, we used to have something called
Sunbeams, and they were people aged 8 to 80
who would
help me get rid of the money in a meaningful
way. I
don't mean to stand on the corner or anything.
And we
had a couple of them who were students actually,
and
they were over at Davidson College in western
North
Carolina, and they were just so busy thinking
up things
to spend money on around there to make things
better over there and
after -- I'm not -- I can't exactly remember
this, but I
do know my grandson, Alexander and I, stopped
at
Davidson coming home from Omaha, and they
put on sort of
a presentation to show me what they were doing,
and it
was so good that both the professor and the
two of us
thought it might be -- turn it into a course.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: So he was the first one, and from
then
on it has spread. There's one in my hometown
now,
Fredericksburg, Virginia, and the professor
there
mirrors every other professor that's involved
with this.
They love the course because they get engaged
students,
you know, you're not fighting somebody typing
all the
time or whatever it is they have to put up
with. They
just adore it. It's always oversubscribed
in every
school where we've presented it, and the kids
get pretty
emotional about the one -- you know, they
go out and
look at local --
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: -- we don't go sending it off to
Bangkok
because we want them to really feel and way
the know you
do it. And so they go out in teams and they
decide
which ones they've interviewed looked the
best to them,
and then that director comes in and speaks
to the class.
There may be four more steps, I don't know,
but I do
know they end up arguing, and that's what
they like the
best. They really -- they pick their favorites,
and boy
do they stand up for them. So that's a good
exercise.
We don't tell them where to spend the money.
They can
divide it up ten different ways or give it
all to
one place, but they've never been able to
do that.
They can't agree on that. So it has benefit.
And as I
said, I don't have anything to say about where
it goes
except it has to be local because that's how
you learn
what your community's like and when you're
high above
Cuyahoga's waters, you may not know what's
going on
below.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So it's been very exciting because
we're creating a whole army of knowledgeable,
bright,
energetic kids. Pardon if I shouldn't say
kids. Young
people? That makes me old people. I don't
like "young
people".
>>JENNIFER: It's fine.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So they're out there, and they've
done
things already that are amazing. There's one
fellow
from the class in Fredericksburg and he went
down to
Honduras and he's building a village and the
schools.
He was one of the heroes of CNN I think couple
of years
ago. And I mean that's the first thing but
we've seen
many other things. And if they can't do it
now, they'll
do it later because they've been inoculated
with the
idea. And it's a good feeling when you know
you can
affect somebody's life it's just thrilling.
It's
absolutely thrilling.
>>JENNIFER: Since you've mentioned the course,
we've got a clip of the Learning by Giving
Foundation
clip that I'd like to show for just a minute
to show our
audience a little bit more about the foundation.
>>DORIS: Okay.
[pause]
>>DORIS: Oh.
>>Male announcer: What class at UNO has been
going above and beyond normal class work [students
giggle] and for a
good cause? The UNO Honors program and school
and
public administration teamed up to offer a
class called
philanthropy and democracy. The goal: To award
$10,000
to a local non- profit. The award later doubled
thanks
to a generous donation by Buffett. And, so
by the
end of the class, two organizations were chosen,
City
Sprouts and the Building Bright Futures D2
program.
>>JENNIFER: So that's just an example of how
the foundation runs.
>>DORIS: Yes. They're a really incredible
group. All of them are, I should say that,
and they're
so bright, and they're just so interested
in it, you
know, and it hits them where they live. They
were so
cute in the way -- I shouldn't use the word
"cute".
They were so adept at what they did, and,
umm --
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: -- I was impressed by them, so in
a
spontaneous manner I said, "I'll double it."
Which I'd
never done before. And then one started to
cry. You
know, they're really engaged. They care about
it. So
they had a lot of good ideas, and I've heard
from quite
of number of them. If they're not ready to
do it now,
they'll be ready to do it some other time.
And it isn't
just a matter of doing good. It's a matter
of doing it
smart. And a lot of time that gets lost, and
every once
in a while you'll see in the paper where some
foundation
has really been misusing the donations and
I come down
pretty hard on that because I -- if we can't
have
integrity here, where are we going to have
it? So they
learn some lessons -- I hope they learn those
lessons.
I'm in there punching for it. But they're
very bright,
and you get the cream of the crop.
>>JENNIFER: So your brother talks about his
version of philanthropy, which is to write
one big
check --
>>DORIS: Oh, yeah.
>>JENNIFER: -- and let it sail.
>>DORIS: Wholesale philanthropy.
>>JENNIFER: And what does he call your version?
>>DORIS: Retail philanthropy.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: I love retail philanthropy because
you
know where it goes, and what it does, and
you can stop
it in a minute if it's not working. Umm, it's
vital, I
think, to be involved in it. I -- you mention
the
prison programs -- I'm only going to say a
word about
that, but I go to the prisons and I meet the
prisoners.
And as much as the school, they're getting
hope, and the
fact that somebody believes in them. I know
that sounds
a little sappy, but it really does work that
way.
Because that's what they lack; I can sort
of fill that
need. And they, of course, are the same sort
of avid
students that we have in these classes. They
want to
learn; they want to learn this -- of course
in the
Learning by Giving--, this particular subject.
So we
don't have a trouble with people not showing
up for
class or anything like that.
>>JENNIFER: No. And in fact I will quote in
your Charlie Rose interview, which was last
year --
>>DORIS: Yeah. Last year.
>>JENNIFER: Umm, you were talking about the
recidivism rate for Sing Sing and it's --
>>DORIS: Oh, boy. Well, you have to first
of
all know, I am from the Midwest. I am a product
the Midwest, and that's a little different
other places
in the country, maybe southern California
or someplace
and so I'm not wasting this money; that's
not in the
Buffett DNA. We just don't do that. I mean,
I did it
once, but I'm not doing it again. [laughter]
Let's put it that
way. And so we try not to make mistakes. But
yeah.
Recidivism rate across the country in state
prisons runs
about 63 percent that's coast-to-coast, and
it means
that the person in prison who's released returns
in
three years, and it's just a cycle and it's
depressing. We
found that -- I started at Sing Sing, and
we've -- and
the record at Sing Sing is -- now remember,
I said
63 percent everywhere. Well, our record at
sing sipping
is zero. They don't come back. They go back
and they
become tax-paying citizens, and they are fathers
in a
fatherless family, and they can add a lot
to our
society. And I think that's a remarkable thing.
And I
like that payoff, and I like the payoff here.
I can't
see it as quickly, but I know it's going to
happen
because there's so much -- well, they just
get turned
on, and they have the energy to follow through,
and when
you get the wonderful letters or see what
happens when
somebody goes to the Wharton School of Finance,
who was
just living, you know, in a trailer or something,
you
know that they've succeeded and their lives
will be
changed, and that's what I'm interested in;
changed
lives. So this army that we're sending out
now, it's
getting bigger by the moment. We just had
an enormous
number of schools. And when I realized that
it was
getting that big then I thought, well, since
I'm not in
the business of building an empire -- which
a lot of
people are, I might tell you -- but that doesn't
appeal
to me at all, so I turned it over to my grandson
and a
bunch of his smart, energetic pals, friends,
cohorts,
buddies, and they're doing a bang-up job.
And then, low
and behold, Google steps in, and now we are
working with
Google and we are thrilled to death. I mean,
this
boggles my mind. I mentioned that. I was a
little
older than you are. Well, I cannot even -- this
is a
different world. I can't even comprehend it,
except
that actually it looks like a lot of fun.
I like those little
scooters.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: And the food everywhere. But imagine
what the combination can do. It's just endless.
>>JENNIFER: That's right. And I think it's
--
you know, I was going to ask, you know, how
do you
inspire young people, kids? I mean, it's different
when
you've been down on your luck, or your trying
to fight
for someone who doesn't have a home or what
have you, or you are
a parent. It's different when you're a young
kid, and
you're already in college. And how do you
engage them
with the Learning by Giving Foundation to
really want to
persons that one-on-one retail ther -- excuse
me.
Retail therapy.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: Retail philanthropy moment, you
know, where they really get that -- where
they really
catch the bug, you know, to do something?
>>DORIS: I think it's the same if it's a prison
or a -- wherever you're working. If you just
give them
hope, and tell them you're confident they
can do it and
applaud them when they do. I know in scholarship
programs we have gotten remarkable results,
but it --
and the first letters that came in and they
continue to
this day they say it's because you have faith
in me.
And so I thought, what's happened to all the
faith in
this country, because that's what I heard
over, and
over, and over, and that's true whether it's
this
program, or that program, or wherever. You
just -- you
get up there and you're obviously grandma
and everybody
loves their grandmother generally, I think,
so I don't
have to overcome the mother thing --
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: -- or the teacher thing. So yeah.
I
think -- and I feel that way. Wholeheartedly
it isn't an
act; I have a lot of faith in them because
they're
there, because they're listening, and because
I think
you can spark them. It's there if you just
give it a
little help. So that's what I do across the
board. It
pays off. Someday I'm going to have to hire
someone who
has a big smile, and send them out to be the
Sunshine
Lady because I can't do them all, you know.
[chuckles] Just that's
all they have to do is qualify.
>>JENNIFER: That's what we call "scaling".
>>DORIS: Oh, is that right? Okay, I must
remember that. Scaling. There's a whole new
vocabulary.
>>JENNIFER: It is indeed, trust me.
>>DORIS: And there's a lot of people that
talk
a lot and don't do anything. This is the antidote
to
that. I went to a meeting at a nameless place
in this
big city and I was just appalled, you know,
they're
talking about the landscape, and the this
-- and
scaling, probably, which I didn't understand,
and about
20 other words that were totally new to me,
but they
weren't doing anything; in the end they were
just
talking. And we're putting out the money,
we're
developing the programs, we're recruiting
everywhere we
can, and now a lot of the work's taken off
me because
we have this crew here today that really know
what
they're doing.
>>JENNIFER: Well, I think it is a natural
partnership because we at Google, I mean,
you're sitting
here, this is a roomful of people, of the
employees that
I get the pleasure of working with every day,
who are
passionate about what they do, they're smart,
they're no
nonsense, they believe in integrity, they
believe in
transparency.
>>DORIS: And they also have a sense of humor,
I
might add.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: Absolutely.
>>DORIS: I noticed that everywhere.
>[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: Absolutely. And so if you have
us
here, you know, and you're just -- there's
something you
haven't yet scratched the surface on, what
-- is there
something you could think of to tell us, hey,
I mean, think out of
the box?
>>DORIS: I'm afraid of what's in the box.
I
really believe in the --
>>JENNIFER: I gotta tell you, you're out of
the
box.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: Well, just old-fashioned virtues
is
all I can come up with, plus the enormous
jump in IQ
that I see between the generations, and the
energy. If
you just put it to work, let 'em go, who know
-- I mean,
who would have imagined this building? Not
me, I tell
you in a million years. I think I'm in another
world.
And so I'm going to live a long, long time
so I can see
what happens because I think great things
are going to
come out of this friendship and collaboration.
Couldn't
ask for anything more.
>>JENNIFER: Well, we certainly hope so, and
we
have, you know, great faith in Maggie Johnson
and our --
>>DORIS: Oh, yeah.
>>JENNIFER: -- team out in Mountain View.
I
have a personal pride for Maggie because she's
part of
the research team which we represent out here
in New
York, as well.
>>DORIS: Well, you have some wonderful people
in your organization. The more I hear, the
more I learn
how many there are, probably about nine -- a
hundred and
12 percent. It's just amazing. Anybody that
has the
imagination to put this place together and
do what you
are doing. Now, I confess, I do not know how
to
turn on a computer so you see I'm illiterate,
ignorant.
How'd I ever get to be in MENSA? But I'm awed
by
what you're doing.
>>JENNIFER: Well, that's the collaboration.
>>DORIS: That is the collaboration. What could
be better? I think I'm coming out the big
winner
because I'm enjoying it so much.
>>JENNIFER: Well, we have today, too. And
I
wanted to invite the audience to ask questions.
Anybody
wanted to -- feel free to walk up and ask
anything you'd
like to. Talk to me a little bit more about
specifically since we mentioned Maggie, Stanford's
philanthropy and civil society.
>>DORIS: Yes. Oh, yes. Stanford's coming on
board; we're really thrilled about that. And
I think --
I can't recite the rest of them because I
know where
we've started and I know where I've been,
but it's
growing so fast. It's -- I feel like we caught
a wave,
I really do. And with all the other troubles
that are
going on everywhere, this is one white hope
to do, you
know, to do good and smart, not dumb.
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: And, and befriend people, I think,
and collaborate. Collaborate's a big deal.
I'm dealing
with somebody, I'll say here's what we'll
do, and maybe
you can do this. Then it doesn't demean them.
That's
the really important thing. It's not like
handouts.
Don't do handouts. We do hand-ups, and we
are very
serious about that. So that sort of keeps
you in line.
Well, we can start a class right here today
I suppose,
but I don't want to keep everybody from their
roller
skating or whatever it is they're out there
--
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: I expect we're going to have a lot
of
fun.
>>JENNIFER: Yes.
>>DORIS: And we're going to be terribly proud
of the product. And just imagine setting all
those
people out to do whatever they're going to
do in their
lives. As I say, it may not be for 30 years,
but they
will know how to do it, and they won't get
fleeced, and
that's very important to me. We're both doing
our thing
in our own way, but I think I'm probably getting
more
fun out of it than just turning it over to
-- you know.
I'm not speaking of the living -- Learning
by Giving,
I'm just talking in general. All the proposals
that
come my way.
>>JENNIFER: Oh, sure. And if someone wanted
to
get a proposal to you, or if we had friends
that -- how
would we go about doing that?
>>DORIS: Well, you just send it to our office,
and just look at our web site, okay --
>>JENNIFER: Look at you promoting the Internet.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: I'm so proud of myself.
>>DORIS: And they'll get all the information
they need, and we will take it under consideration.
And
it's really a pleasure being here. Just a
tremendous
pleasure. I'm going to leave here with one
of those --
what do you call it? Scooters.
>>JENNIFER: Yes.
>>DORIS: No. I'll have to steal it I guess.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: That wouldn't be a good example at
all, but I think that's so clever.
>>JENNIFER: Trust me, it comes in very handy.
>>DORIS: I'm sure it does. You're in a hurry.
>>JENNIFER: Exactly. Or there's a really long
floor to try to get across to.
>>DORIS: Yeah! This building's enormous.
>>JENNIFER: It is. It's a rather large
footprint here for--.
>>DORIS: Well, you've got a great thing here,
an amazing thing. We're glad to be associated
with you,
just tickled to death because that just -- imagine
how
that expands the kind of work you can do.
>>JENNIFER: Absolutely.
>>DORIS: It's wonderful.
>>Female#1: We have a question here
>>Female #2: Hi, Doris . I'm just wondering
if you can
share the story of the person you helped that
touched
you the most.
>>DORIS: Oh, my gosh. Oh. Well... uh, first
of all, when we're doing individual things,
we do people
who have bad luck, not people who have made
wrong
choices because it bothers you for sort of
paying them
off for making a dumb decision. I've made
some, so I
can refer to it that way. So I'll just take
the most
recent one because I don't, there are hundreds
and
hundreds of them now, I'm telling you. Umm...
I got two
recently and -- just the other day. One was
a -- I have
a crew up in Maine that handles individual
cases, and my
brother pays for that part, so he's involved.
And this
woman had written in and I can't remember
the illness
she had because we were in the mall, but she
had a
motorized wheelchair and to get to the bus
stop she had
to go a mile, and whether snow, sleet, rain,
mud, the
whole thing, and I don't even remember her
illness, but
I'll tell you, MS is a big illness in this
country today
because we've helped more people that have
MS than I can
imagine. So she needed a van, something that
would
handle the wheelchair and get her where she
was going.
So our rule up in Maine is if it comes in
at 5,000 or
less they can go ahead and use their own judgment
because they're all smart and they're in the
-- in the
deal. They understand it. So this would take
a little
more. We never buy new ones; we always buy
used ones,
but we know every used van dealer in the country.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: They are so knowledgeable up there.
And so I said, well, go ahead. And then a
few days
later, the girl who was handling the program
called me
what she said -- it was just amazing. She
called the
lady back and said she was going to get her
van, when
she said there was this long silence and then
uncontrollable weeping. And it just made all
the -- and
it was -- once again, it gets back to the
thing about
having a personal connection. It wasn't just
the van;
she made that clear. It was the fact that
someone,
somewhere, recognized her and wanted to help
her. These
are invisible people in many cases, and as
these legions
go forth from these programs, think how many
more we can
help with that. That happens oh, gosh, I can't
-- oh,
and then another thing we stress is paying
it forward
in every one. I was up in Maine a year ago
and the
phone rang, and a woman called -- said, my
name is
Susan. I can't remember her last name. She
said, you
saved our family a year ago. She said, we
still don't
have much money, but I have collected over
4,000 pairs
of shoes and they're going to Haiti. Now,
I love that
story; that's true. And it shows it's a catching
thing.
If you do it on a very kindly, caring, reasonable
basis,
and it isn't as they say a handout -- that's
money
wasted. So that's going on all over the country
and
when we turn this group loose, I mean really,
it's going
to be monumental.
>>JENNIFER: Another question here.
>>Female #3: Thank you so much for coming
today. One
of the questions I had was you make the distinction
between those who've had poor luck and poor
circumstance, and those who've possibly made
bad
choices. Those so often go hand in hand that
circumstances often lead to bad choices, and
I was
wondering how your organization makes the
distinction.
I'm sure it's a many-layered question, but--
>>DORIS: It's a many-layered answer, too,
as a
matter of fact. In some cases, yes, you can
see it, but
you try to balance it out. But other cases
are so
unmistakably bad luck. Nobody did anything
wrong. Can
I tell one more?
>>JENNIFER: Of course.
>>DORIS: Okay. I got a letter from a woman,
a
nurse, she was a nurse by occupation, lived
in Arapaho,
Colorado, and she had a twin sister who lived
in
Memphis, Tennessee. Both of these sisters,
twins, had
girls the same age, ten years old, so nothing
followed
this. So the ten-year-old from Memphis, Tennessee,
probably got on a gray hound bus and went
to visit her
cousin of the same age on a cool Colorado
one summer,
and presumably had a wonderful time, and then
she went
back home. Now, her mother in Tennessee was
divorced
and she was working two jobs, and keeping
her children
going and so on. She had no health insurance,
of
course. And when this little girl got back
there, she
had a spot under her left eye, and it didn't
seem to go
away so her mother took her to a hospital,
the emergency
room, and they gave her Noxema or something
and sent
them home. Then they went back a second time
a few
weeks later because it wasn't having any effect
on this
place, and then the third time they went in,
they saw a
doctor, and he did a biopsy and sent it off
to some
really good places. When it came back, she
had a
disease -- what is that? What do you call
that? It's
creepy kind of thing. What is it in fungus.
Yeah. It
was a fungal infection or condition, and there
were two
people in this country that had it and 43
that had it in
Bangladesh. I mean, it's just -- how would
you ever get
that? She went on the bus, she had a good
time, she
came home on the bus, and now by time I heard
from them,
I then contacted the mother, and she was at
that point
working nights so she could be with her daughter
in the
daytime in the hospital, and the girl had
been in
intensive care at different times, and it
was spreading,
and she was blind in one eye. And she could
go home for
a while, but she was terrified to go home
for fear her
friends would make fun of her, you know, because
her
face was mixed up. So we were able -- the
woman sounded
like death warmed over and so I said how are
you getting
along financially? She said well, I'm going
to lose my
car, I'm going to lose my home and so on.
I said, well,
send me your bills. Now, I don't usually do
impulsive
things like that, but this had to be addressed.
So we
were able to do that for her, and I mean,
that's my idea
of bad luck. It's pretty high standard. And
then
you'll have some dilettante calling you and
saying, "I
owe $80,000 in credit cards and my husband
told me if I
did this again he's going to divorce me."
And in the
end we talked about things she might do. There
were
some avenues to get through this. She had
a different
mailbox for all the bills that came in. I
mean, she was
good at this. [laughter] But it was 80,000
she had done it before
as I say. Unfortunately, they were going to
build a new
house -- buy a new house, and they were going
to check
the credit and she was in trouble. So she
said, well,
what do you think I ought to do? That I said
well --
she told me that she had had a small inheritance
from --
I said I'd apply that to the debt, and so
-- and then in
the end she said, you mean, you aren't going
to help me?
And I said no, we're not, because this doesn't
meet our
criteria.
>>JENNIFER: Sure.
>>DORIS: But those are -- they're not as -- and
then there are the crazy ones. These are always
really
interesting. I heard from the Virgin Mary,
folks, and
they may not have happened to any of you,
and I --
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: I'm very sad to have to tell you,
she's not a very nice person.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So once in a while we get somebody
that gives us a laugh. But anybody that works
--
anybody that's involved in charity of this
kind is going
to be having a wonderful life; I can tell
you that. And
it makes changes in your own personality sometimes.
You
know, they don't -- aren't quite as self-centered
and
don't think they're as poor as they're putting
on.
>>JENNIFER: Well, what I -- I think one of
the
things that I was curious about is I'm sure
you have a
lot of people ask you what it's like to have
Warren as a
brother, but I --
>>DORIS: I can tell ya.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: Well, okay.
>>DORIS: It's great.
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: We really do have a lot in common
now
and he's -- well, he urged me to write the
book; that
was his idea, and --
>>JENNIFER: Did he write the forward as well?
>>DORIS: Yeah. He wrote the forward without
reading the book. He likes the book enormously.
He
sent it to everybody he knows because it's
an honest
book. I mean, you could write and not tell
anything
about that event in 1987, and the things that
followed
it. But it wouldn't be true. It wouldn't tell
the
whole thing so he admired that because a lot
of people
don't do that. So it was a -- actually, it
was a great
healing thing for the two of us and so -- I
send him
some of the more outrageous things and some
of the thank
yous. Do you know what? A lady saw that show
you're
speaking of, Charlie Rose --
>>JENNIFER: Mm hmm.
>>DORIS: -- in California, and she sent me
a
letter and she said I've saved up money during
my
lifetime to help other people, but she liked
the way we
were doing it and and she said I'd like to
give you that
savings thing. And so I thought well, we had
our
lawyer -- we have a pro bono lawyer. There's
some
things that go with this, kids. If they know
you're
doing the right things, they want to help
you. We get a
hot of things like that. But he's probably
the best.
So he wrote and you have to contact the lawyer,
and I
didn't think that it'd ever work out because
it was
maybe just some kind of a spontaneous thing.
Well, we
got a check for $187,000. So people -- you
know, they may engage with you on you know
for a quarter
or something, but some little act of kindness
and
goodness, and then this woman -- I mean, I'm
just
astounded. That was a real vote of confidence.
So we
felt good about that. And we're going to put
it in some
very special cause, you know.
>>JENNIFER: Absolutely. Well, between the
Learning from Giving Foundation.
>>DORIS: You see, everybody feels good. The
person who is empowered by what we do -- I'm
going to
tell one more, and then I promise to stop.
This is one
of the first ones, and it was a woman who
wrote to us
from South Carolina, and she had been a nurse
in a
doctor's office. This all panned out. We check
everything. And then she got arthritis and
she couldn't
do it any longer. So I said, well, Willie
Mae -- that
was actually her name -- Willie Mae, is there
anybody
else in your home now? And she said yes, my
husband,
and we always check it. It's usually a family
situation. It's going to take the whole family
to pull
it together. So I said well, is he working
now? She
said well, no. He was driving a truck and
he didn't
care for his -- you know, the route, and so
he's at home.
I had visions of him sitting in a Barcalounger
at that
moment. And so I said, well, tell him that
if -- when
he -- if he gets a job -- when he gets a job,
that we
will match his check until -- from now until
Christmas.
She said the house was tumbling down and the
furnace
wasn't going to work. And so one week later,
we got a
copy of a check where he was raking pine needles,
the
next week he was working at Lowe's Hardware.
We want
cooperation, collaboration. That's probably
a little
different than what other people do. Because
it's
private money; we don't have to give it unless
we want
to, and they don't have to take it unless
they're happy
with it. So it works out equitably.
>>JENNIFER: So I think my last question, we
obviously know what it's like to have Warren
-- oh, we
have one more question, but I was going to
ask, what's
it like to have Doris Buffett as a sister?
What would
Warren say?
>>DORIS: I hadn't really thought about that.
I
know he's very proud of me. I do know that,
and that
feels good. Everybody feels good when they're
appreciated. And we'd come from a rocky place
so that
was especially dear to my heart. We're living
out what
I think my father taught us. We were very,
very lucky
to have an outstanding dad who was a member
of Congress,
but I don't want you to get upset about that.
He was
not the -- not who we're dealing with now.
And in fact
when he died, the Omaha World-Herald wrote
and editorial that said he was known
for his blazing integrity. So you can't beat
that. And
he was very kind and all that, too. So we
share that
and -- in a big way, and he set the markers
for us and
it's great to be able to do something about
it. So
I'm -- of course I'm grateful that he had
a bright idea.
So did somebody in Google. You know, it really
is
magic. It happens fast, and it's wonderful
if you do
the right stuff with it.
>>JENNIFER: And then it multiplies.
>>DORIS: And then it multiplies. That's right.
>>JENNIFER: We'll take our last question.
>>Female #4: Hello. Thank you so much for
coming. I
was just wondering if you could talk a little
bit about
the process that goes into selecting the schools
chosen
for the Learning by Giving program. How do
you pick?
>>DORIS: Well. I think we announce that the
course is available because there's always
some
professor, a professor, maybe more, that is
very
enthusiastic about it. Then right away we
got the right
person teaching the course because it's something
they
believe in. And I think they announce it and
it's like,
build a field and they will come. Because
they all show
up, and they're passionate about it. We like
passion
because it really moves them forward with
a little
control and --
[Laughing]
>>DORIS: So it's very simple. Everything we
do
is really simple, you know. There's nothing
convoluted.
We don't have to be contracts with people
-- we just --
we operate with kindness, and compassion,
and common
sense, and the only thing we ask is collaboration.
Because then we're part of a team, you know.
It isn't
somebody dipping into their basket and handing
out
hundred dollar bills it's not that at all.
And they go
forward with it. It's really exciting.
>>JENNIFER: Well, thank you so much for coming
and visiting with us today. I know you're
staying for
lunch, so enjoy.
>>DORIS: I'm sure I will.
[Laughing]
>>JENNIFER: I believe we have a few books
if
I'm not mistaken here and so if you want to
stay after
and get a book, I think we have some here.
And thank
you again for coming. We really appreciate
it.
>>DORIS: Oh, it was a joy.
[Clapping]
>>JENNIFER: And we look forward to working
with
you.
>>DORIS: Thank you very much.
[Clapping]